suivant suivant bonjour tu viens
t'asseoir ici a juste posé deux trois
petites questions
maggie j'ai jamais atteint dans la nuit
bons trades paierait tous les autres
films ah ouais comme mirettes
ouais mais moi je sais pas j'ai pas pété
7 euros t batteux monde se fout de
magalas l'école alors ça ça là mais ça
va y révèle toujours pour tous toi par
exemple sans te demander de jouer un
enfant la plupart en main depuis que ma
paroisse ont divorcé bas et c'est même
pire ils ont des problèmes comme ça et
paient des fois j'ai un petit peu triste
intérieur tu peux vous poser une
question via wave asie c'est look avait
choisi e de courgettes attendant c'est
pas moi ça c'est dans le livre c'est sa
maman d'un livre elle appelle son père
son projet tu vois ça ça ne plaît pas
pour jeunes incorrect c'est simple pour
ico est
simplifie à c'est moi qui ai pris dans
ce film je peux changer de nom
les enfants je vous présente votre
nouveau camarade picard votre nouveau
camarade courgettes
mais j'aurais plutôt pada du sata 6 mois
sur du calme du calme les enfants je
voulais c'est à tout à l'heure mais
c'est pas tout à l'heure
batta soir mon grand alors je reprends
donc comme je vous disais la vache et un
ruminant ce qui peut être que mes 100 la
prison la pente
bon c'est bien tout ça ça a l'air
chouette
bon là c'est chouette
qu'est ce qui à mon grand
on se sera moins bien quand tu
reviendras plus tu crois que je viens
par obligation je sais pas c'est ton
travail donc je vais pas mon travail je
viens de voir parce que je t'aime bien
moi aussi je t'aime bien oh oui ils
viennent pas ton fric je crois pas sur
toi ahmed
il croit que c'est toi qui a mis son
père en prison qu'est ce qu'elle me
faisait là on sera au top comme une
porte de prison seulement